like I get so many of these comments
that dedicated an entire song to call it
raping versus rapping happens way too
commonly one's a form of music others a
felony not that hard unless you're not
that smart
if you have two peas your M&M if you
have 1p you need consent
it happens all the time once inform love
me
the others the freakin crime not that
hard if you take this long
if you have to piece your Kanye West if
you have one piece you're not well aware
that here and there a time boat can
happen
finger slipped your thumb just missed
it's a fairly common habit and I'm not
trying to save the world
no I just want to say that if you can't
tell the difference they ought to take
your keyboard away all right man versus
rapping shouldn't even be a thing but
the internet is full of hooni teaching
so when you find a mine this guy makes
this wrong offense but the only thing
you have to do sing this song to them
thank you on my youtube channel I think
there's a picture of my face somewhere
um no that's not the picture I wanted No
can that please don't zoom in please
don't what are you doing please stop no
don't don't do the nose thing don't damn
it all right